[Music]
okay everyone so this is my review
of episode nine of the handmaid's tale
this was directed by
elizabeth moss again but this time
written by eric tuckman
and ally monroe i am going to break my
review into three parts as this episode
is broken down in three parts first
we'll start with lydia janine and
esther's story
then we'll go the waterfords and we'll
finish off with june so we see now
esther aka mrs keys we haven't seen in a
while she's a handmaid
as is janine again and what's
interesting is this
scene opens up with lydia looking at
this tray right where the
fork is excused the food is not eaten
and
this is something that's a no-no right
but what it's setting up is that esther
is this rebellious character again she's
also under the influence
of june right as lydia will even
reference where she's like it's so hard
to be good when you have such a bad
example
and what's fascinating about this is
that with janine watching it's like
janine's watching
a reflection of herself when she first
met aunt lydia in season one it was the
same way
janine was acting right and then she had
her eye taken out because of it
so it makes so much sense too that
janine would be the character that would
know
how to deal with these situations the
best and how to avoid consequences like
that
now what was really impressive to me was
this shot we got
that like the testimony shot it slowly
starts on this
really wide shot and slowly moves in no
cuts one shot to end
on a close-up of lydia and this is the
scene where it looks like almost the
last supper and i love
that it's lit with just candle light
here and a little light coming through
the window but it's very natural and i
think
that's always the best looking shots in
the handmaid's tale and kind of fits the
world really well
it's so interesting though to me every
time we see like how the ants operate
and what they do in their time you know
with them gossiping and the way they're
eating at this table
it kind of just gives me that same like
thrill when i see at like a calendar
about nuns dancing it's like this
interesting thing to see
what these ants do in their free time
but you see aunt ruth and the other aunt
on the side of lydia are talking about
how they should
discipline esther and to make her behave
and one's suggesting a feeding tube
with restraints and the other is just
saying to cut out her tongue and this
is what you know sets janine off she
can't handle hearing this anymore
but it's the difference in lydia we're
slowly seeing where
she in the past would probably jump to
just taking a tongue out but that's not
what she's doing here and
what even shows more of lydia's growth
here which i really like to see because
as i've said it's taking a long to get
to like more of her redemption
with her but it's getting there and her
having now aunt ruth say
you know she is useful she's a fruitful
girl and
them suggesting her even going to the
breeding colonies where they originally
want her to go so that already shows you
the change here that i don't think was
set up great last episode where it just
jumped to janine saying don't make me a
handmade again maybe they should have
had lydia mentioned she's needed an
episode the breeding qualities and then
we could see
right away that she's already made a
progressive choice to have
janine be a handmade and not go there so
there is some change in lydia going on
and the person to affect her the most to
change is janine and even when aunt ruth
mentions her troubled past and like what
commander would want her
that really ticks lydia off and it shows
again
how much she cares about janine but how
much her love for janine will slowly
start
especially this episode to change the
wheels on how lydia thinks about things
so i really love this scene right
because it shows lydia in her office and
she's looking
at households for janine she got
janine's picture and there's like this
commander
and his wife there the davis couple but
she's like you'll be all right dear i'll
take care of you but what janine does is
she informs
lydia of esther's past her troubled past
how
esther was abused not just by her
commander but by multiple men on this
farm and to kind of give her a break
here but this is where janine's growth
as a character comes and this has been
set up all season right where she
wants to be taken seriously to show
she's smart
that she is useful and this is when she
saves the day by suggesting that someone
meaning her
safely tell esther what would happen if
she doesn't obey instead of jumping to
punishment
and this will slowly start to get lydia
to change in how she views
how to correct handmates because she's
like i'll put esther's correction on
hold for now
and then lydia suggests janine to go
bring her breakfast
giving janine the shot now giving a
chance at janine's way
so it's just brilliant because janine is
seeing through lydia's cracks
and it's not janine being old janine
don't be fooled by that there is a
smarter play going on with jeanine her
character has grown to get here and it's
been earned brilliantly
from that episode of milk and this is
the point of the review i start
really sweating because it's 93 degrees
in new york today
and i am wearing this heavy trench coat
so if you can please give a like
subscribe
you know become a member maybe tip if
you're watching on the live stream
praise be
okay but i really loved about the
directing elizabeth moss here and
how as a little hardener directing last
episode this episode is completely
different how she does it she's giving
all these creative shots
shots that have meaning visual meaning
but also a feel
and i think one of my favorite shots
it's so simple but amazing was
just janine walking through this hallway
to esther alone right
and it's like that horror vibe and it's
amazing
how great this works janine being away
from june because the first time we're
seeing janine without someone kind of
guiding her
and having to step up for herself and be
a leader herself so that was like a real
moment i felt where she's like okay she
knows this is like
you know little janine now becoming this
brave woman which is awesome
and i love that she's in these
circumstances by herself
it's really fascinating and she's
running on her own instinct her own plan
no one else's
but i love now when she gets in the room
esther you know this is a call back to
pretty sure season two and june is in
the white outfit she's chained
to that pole and that it's literally
shot the same lighting so again great
job it was
getting that to reflect perfectly and i
love esther keeps asking about june like
where's june
you know and janine's like forget june
like this is totally
her brady bunch marshall marsha marsha
that's like all she hears about she's
sick of it like
she's not here we're here and you have
to take care of yourself now i love this
again showing a handmade now kind of
take things
on their own and it's a different
approach than june would take so it's
the janine approach right
to me it's very smart she knows how to
play the game and she's giving esther
truth like
they are not going to let you die they
will keep hurting you again and again
until you do what they say
that is their job and great shot choice
by elizabeth moss here because
she is just keeping close-ups on esther
but keeping
janine mostly in medium shots because
again the way the emotional impact in
the scene is happening on esther
and first too esther kind of accuses
janine in a way of like
being their puppet but again don't be
fooled by that like this isn't janine
doing that janine's just getting smart
and she's like when you do eat i'll
talent lydia and she'll let you go
outside it's a really nice day i thought
this was a really just touching moment
and like i don't know why it just works
so well for me and maybe that's also
because we got madeleine brewer mckenna
grace both
fabulous actresses here but it's just
showing you that hope that janine can
give as a leader
and i love this tracking shot now of
janine and esther coming down the
hallway
and there's this eerie music playing and
the best part of madeleine brewer's
acting
here is the little things right keeping
in character as janine and that's when
esther's saying what she needs to say to
lydia and like janine's mouthing the
words to her even though esther's got it
you know i just love that and how
excited
janine is because she's doing something
big here but there's a very important
reaction shot here after aunt lydia
kisses janine and thanks her and says
you're the best
that you know this aunt is like okay
she's seeing lydia's
softening up and that's a no-no for the
ants but with the light on lydia here
you know it's her seeing through janine
that there's another way to correct
behavior of a bad handmaid instead of
just actually taking somebody's eye out
so
slowly but surely lydia's becoming a
little better of a person
but it's showing you the effect someone
like janine and probably only janine
could have on someone like aunt lydia
maybe aunt lydia doesn't change
through the ways of june but through
someone like janine so i
loved everything with janine here and
lydia and esther it moved the plot along
and it progressed
all of their characters and it sets up
some really interesting stuff so i
really like that so let's switch over to
the waterfords now
so we see the most depressing baby
shower ever
with serena and fred so there's these
little moments i just laugh at fred it's
like ridiculous and i like they're kind
of leaning into that even when he's like
all excited about like
this mini commander outfit someone got
them but he's saying how they're
inspiring the people now they're beacon
of hope
and he's giving her this card and she's
like oh i can read this now
now that nobody's watching so serena's
got the big dig there
and fred's like oh you know i've made
mistakes in the past but he then goes so
far as to serena
just write a book again which is crazy
too i like they're kind of going with
that and again
any stuff relating to serena's past is
so interesting to me
you know i think serena still is the
most interesting character on the show
and they have much they can do with her
so it's interesting the next scene we
see serena is already starting to write
you know and this is gonna have a big
impact especially as we saw those
followers
outside and it seems like also they're
setting up something that's not totally
gilead with the waterfords but something
that's still bad but somewhere
you know it's a different floss because
fred's gonna have to adjust i don't want
to get too into this because it's more
theory but i do have
my theories about that but we'll get to
that but what's crazy is we get
a visit from mrs putnam here naomi i
mean i forgot she was on the show
she's a great actress it was good to see
her so they justify though
you know the putnam's been able to visit
that serena's due dates approaching and
that's how they got in
so be it it's a little ridiculous but i
can get past it the best line of the
episode
and the most clever line maybe the whole
season is when
serena asks mrs putnam about angela and
how she's doing
and she's like she's an issue with
biting but maybe that's genetic
what a great line it's hysterical
because
obviously because that's janine's baby
and she is the one who bit mrs putnam
and we get a nice
rack focused shot of mrs putnam noticing
serena writing which is
huge huge so this is where stuff gets
really juicy where
mrs putnam is giving her all these gifts
from the other wives and serena is like
pulled back by this because it's like
she's like i thought you know
people would see me as a traitor miss
pose like oh you do what you had to do
for the baby
and she suggests that if this ordeal
isn't over
by the time the baby's born that they
could take care of the baby in her house
and that it belongs back in gilead this
is when like that
serena horror music kicks in she doesn't
like to hear this
and she's like well i expect to be
released and have a fresh start by the
time that happens
and again she's also right serena where
she's like
you know you might say the wives are
cool with this but i don't think the
commanders are down for
me coming back there like there will be
some consequences but miss putnam's like
nonsense you're going to return as a
hero
kind of like what fred was saying but
again as serena is making
a guess about how the commanders react
to her and what she's done
you get a good hint that she's right
because then it cuts this scene with
fred talking to warren and he's got a
totally different tone
and you see how piss-fred is or he's
like has there been any negotiation on
my behalf
like exchanging a prisoner and you know
putnam is basically
saying that they'd rather not risk other
kidnappings and other bad things
happening for gilead to save fred and
fred's
this is complete betrayal for fred this
is what he values the most his honor in
the gilead system all the work he's done
and he's like and you guys are just
leaving me behind like not even fighting
for me
so it's another great written character
moment
for fred and how his character can now
start maybe changing good or bad
probably worse but it's changed this is
big for him
and just for icing on the top for mr put
him just to say
we'll we'll keep you in our thoughts and
prayers which is like yeah we're not
doing anything
so crazy i like they went that route
with this and then
wrapping up the waterford story in this
episode right you have fred and serena
in this chapel
and he's like it's like they have erased
me left me here to rot
our son's freedom will be what sustains
me and then serena's like
they could take him away gilead come for
our son and
a mother alone they think the baby
belongs to the state
which is so true that's how definitely
gilly i would think and then she says
something i'm sure the fans love to hear
where she's like they would send me to
the colonies they could make me a
handmade this has been something people
have been
dying to see and have been predicting on
the reddit for a while just probably
people hearing that got all excited
because that would be ultimate justice
for serena but fred's like look
it's not going to happen i promise i'll
do anything in my power to make sure you
and your son are protected and serena
another disc goes
what power what could you possibly do
from here but what's brilliant about
this
is fred says have faith so this
perfectly
sets up the big reveal at the end of the
episode
with fred just saying that line that
something was changing here and
something was up which we'll get to so
let's now shift to june's storyline the
main storyline
so luke gets exactly what happened to
hannah now that june's told him he's not
holding it against june at all he's very
understanding
he gets the situation but he suggests no
let's get
handed and we can still do it from here
so who's the first one up they try
talking to is commander lawrence
and here comes the funny man comes on
the phone he's like hello june hello
canada so now i'm nauseated by this
character of commander lawrence it's for
a couple reasons again i've said his
character should have been done with
last season
because now he is literally just a
plotbot
and he's convenient for every turn they
need in the script
this whole scene was ridiculous to me
it's the one scene i didn't like in the
episode and he's informing june
everything she needs to hear
like that janine is with aunt lydia and
what was the most ridiculous part about
this
was him offering a deal that he would
get 10 kids that
they got out together him and june for
hannah right so at that point you're
like what is this guy's motivation and
deal but also
how do we go from him reading story time
to these kids
last season in the finale and then he's
willing to
trade to bring 10 of them back to gilead
i don't buy it for a second
at this point i'm just convinced that
this guy is not a real person
and he's the one character in the show
that has come through from the script
and it's not the other way around which
is problematic
and it's annoying because this isn't the
first time i've felt this in a
transition of seasons
for lawrence like lawrence i felt when
he got
emily out with june's baby then he was a
real jerk in the beginning of season
three and this continues on again where
it's like
okay but then if he does something
really nice the end of last season
getting the kids out and reading them
story time and then again he's back to
this
other lawrence he's like i don't see it
either as this complicated character or
he goes both ways it's like i i don't
buy it i really think he's their way out
of a lot of traps in the script
and i'm just really sick of his
character at this point i just need to
get that rant out because
that was it for me but he does nothing
right and
it's also kind of a wasted scene in that
sense too
but at the same time again it gets june
to get information she needs to hear for
the script
so another thing i in the past not
really this season he's done pretty good
but i've been a little hard
on the actor of luke and his acting um i
think one of my issues is he
has to react his character looks direct
a lot and it's tough because he's not
giving a lot of lines it's more of
a lot of reacting to june and things
around him and that is obviously tough
as an actor because you're acting just
through your face
but a lot of times when he's doing that
i feel like i'm watching someone who's
acting
right the key to good acting is you
forget you're watching
a show but i always feel like i'm
watching someone trying to act no
offense
to the actor because i think here he
does an amazing job i thought this was
the best scene ever
and luke's best scene ever is when he's
suggesting
to june to go to nick because he knows
it's the best thing for his daughter you
can put aside that drama with him and
nick
right that you know there's gonna be
that jealousy and you know
can you trust june around nick it's a
lot right but he does this perfectly and
he shows that perfectly and like
i like they kept him honest too he's
like no i don't want you to go to nick
but
you should and he gives a great idea of
her to bring nicole because like that is
something too you would want
nick to see that so he fully does help
hannah you know seeing
that baby will bring that out in him but
you know i like this whole mystery
everyone's having these theories about
is
nicole really nicks or is it fred
waterford it's because we now know
he can have children so it's very
interesting and the other thing that was
weird to me i don't know if anyone was
feeling this i'm sure someone was but
like i felt like it was a little too
easy
how like two ello was just able to get
them to see nick i feel like we're
losing a little bit
of canada and gilead having this
distance between them and like how hard
it is to get them to even like cooperate
with each other and it's like all of a
sudden it's like
boom you know we got laurence on the
phone and then now a sudden it's like
yeah we'll get you to see nick it's like
it makes it kind of downplay how hard it
was for you know them to get to canada
that it's so easy to kind of just go
back
but again i can let that slide a bit and
you know it's interesting when she says
goodbye to luke
right and she drives off to go see nick
you see this like
big smile comes on her face there's like
a difference what i like what they do
about
luke nick and elizabeth moss in this
love triangle they have because it is
one
either if you like that or not that the
show does that they do it does actually
show that most people in life love
more than one person that way you know
and i think june's clearly that case and
it's a different like
excitement she has with nick nick's like
the the little girl type love you know
it's like
all this joy and it's shown through the
whales with moss has
elected twice this season to film her
embracing nick and
to decide to have that big smirk on her
face when she's going there and
you saw that in episode 3 when they're
on the bridge and she does that 360 shot
and that happy music
that happens again here when they kiss
and all that sunlight's there and the
kid's right there it's like almost like
she films it in a dream sequence for
june like it is this like what if like
if it was me him and this baby
and i think there's a different type of
love there too because you know they
fell in love
through struggle through going through
hell together so
it does have weight that i don't think
you can ever let go i don't want to get
all sappy here
but you know that shows too another
point i want to show on that is that
even the way she likes to have when june
gets there in the snow to nick you know
we don't
see nick clear he's out of focus and him
just saying june
you know it's showing her state of mind
just hearing that and hearing his voice
makes her smile
it's a complete different thing because
i mean when she saw
luke like on the vote like they just
kind of hugged and like okay
you know this is like whoo she just gets
happy but you see nick the big surprise
wasn't the wedding ring it was that he's
got some grays coming in his hair so
gileads run a little low on the just for
men and talking about just clever lines
here that this script had this episode
i like this one where june's like how's
it going down in gilead and he says
hanging in there and she goes
poor choice of words very clever and i
like when the show can kind of sneak in
any bit of humor to just kind of ease
the tension
and look nick's getting all the brownie
points right he's put together already
stuff
beforehand and knowing june was gonna
look for her she loves this
but we find that he is friendlies in
that area which i had talked about like
he must have a lot of connection as a
commander so it'll be interesting how
much
nick can help from his end and that we
learned she's in colorado springs
she's doing good in school but he's like
it's gonna be impossible to figure out
there's guardians everywhere but not for
june you know there's always a way with
her but that was the big line i think
you know everyone's going like oh i went
like he's like i wish i had run away
with you when i had the chance you know
they have this romantic embrace
and it was important though them to show
that nick was good with the baby
right and that he wasn't like in denial
about this baby and that he got her
a doll and it's funny because he's like
yeah gillian has the best selection
of stuff just this creepy old doll but
that was the thing it was like you know
he says to june hey june try to be happy
and she's like you two again just a
moment of levity here it's just good to
see
some happiness between our characters
we've seen go through so much but yeah
there's that big twist now and you can
like see that nick is putting back on a
wedding ring
so you know who is she but you see only
elizabeth moss can pull off such great
complicated emotions when she's driving
off like again it's showing you how
crazy love can be right where she's got
all these emotions she's got this like
giddiness about what just happened
but you could tell there's a little
guilt there too because again you know
she's married to luke you know she's
with luke at the moment it's a little
different because she's not just with
gilead now with nick it's like you know
she's still seeing luke again so
you know there's it's interesting okay
so but this is where things get great
payoff and crazy
is luke is happy seeing photos of hannah
that she got from nick it's a nice
moment and it's perfectly shifts because
it literally when tula even speaks the
music shifts and it becomes like just
complete craziness and then it shows
that all this stuff he did
tulo does not care about hannah he
doesn't care about june getting hannah
he did this out of guilt because of what
he was gonna have to tell them about
commander waterford and it was just
brilliantly written
and just the suspense bringing up slowly
when he's like we have a new asset in
toronto now
knows how the system operates can advise
us and when luke's just like okay who is
it and he says
fred waterford it was perfect this is tv
at its
best in reveals like this because you're
feeling that shock that your main
character of june's feeling in that
moment like
what but the bigger drop of the hat to
june
and to us is when she goes why would he
give all this intel
and he goes in exchange for his freedom
the prosecution has dropped his charges
so it's confirmed that he didn't clear
this with them
tolo he just like yeah basically fred's
going free
and this is just insane and then june
sees right through him and goes so my
testimony spooked him you knew that and
used this to flip
him so it really shows tulo is that
snake we were all kind of theorizing and
you see tulo
justifies that there was you know you
let one fish go to get the bigger fish
but this is
a great commentary on just politics and
society today where like any of that
kind of thinking has really set us back
in history you know like there's no win
to letting fred waterford type of person
free nothing good can come from that
these are the type of choices that
always keep the world going backwards
and i feel like if i can relate like
tulo is like
to me anyone who's dealt with like an hr
rep and they won't
act like they're helping you and they're
really not they don't have any interest
in actually helping you it's like
they're for the business to for the
bigger thing it's always a bigger thing
it's nothing about you
which always sucks but i loved that
this sound effect almost sounds like a
crashing wave comes in
when jun's sitting there and she's
getting really angry and after he's
walked away
and they're like june june but she goes
into possessed june mode this is the
june we saw
last season when she yelled at natalie
for being a rat
and she's like that man is a rapist you
know what he did to me and all those
women
i mean elizabeth moss again how many
times can i praise her she's incredible
actress and i love she never holds back
and i like when she's screaming that i
will kill you i will kill you
i got chills down my spine this was
incredible to me and
what made it and sealed the deal and
just like kicked my butt watching it
was right when it cuts out on her
screaming in full anger and all that
rage coming out that was pent up
it's hearing that crashing wave over the
credits you know chef's kiss
that's how you get goosebumps leading to
a finale at the end of a penultimate
episode
and this is why i give different range
different episodes and why i was a
little harder on last week's where
a lot of people gave me crap for not
liking last week's episode that much and
i was hard on it but it's like look
there's always a higher standard to go
for it like i said the writing last
episode
you know it feels like it's written for
twitter it's on the nose where this was
like you know
everything's clicking because the
writing is for feel it's
clever and it's also progressing the
story and also bringing in all these
character arcs
to have conflict but growth and change
so you are back on the edge of your seat
you're invested
it's entertaining it's just all working
to me here and perhaps it wasn't the
most because i was harder directing last
episode
saying that wasn't a lot of changing of
shots wasn't that imaginative
but this was this was the complete
opposite so i'm thoroughly blown away by
that
and if i'm gonna give someone a harsher
rating when they do
you know not a great job in my eyes when
they do great i'm obviously gonna praise
it i
take every episode and look at it you
know as its own thing so this was great
to me i'm giving it a 9.6 it makes me
really excited for what's to come now
where i was a little hesitant and
worried where they were going to go with
this
but i think it's awesome that janine is
her own story now in a way with lydia
and it'll be the perfect pairing
also with esther i want to see more of
her clearly but i like that this is like
bringing a little more heightened
tension to jun's story in canada now
that we're
ramping this up like what is going to
happen here with fred waterford i'm
really excited to see what's going to go
down in the finale
let me know what you thought of it down
below i'd love to hear your thoughts i
read every comment try to respond to as
many as i can
if you love what i do here you know
please subscribe it helps me in so many
ways you have no idea
you can also check me out on tic tac now
i do shorter reviews there
and instagram reels and even some
youtube shorts you'll see here
but if you really really like it i'd
love any support i can get
you can become a member today there's
three different tiers you get exclusive
perks but it'll really help me to do
this full
time one day and be able to review more
stuff for you guys to enjoy
thank you so much for watching me and
i'll see you next time